29 juin 1949 voici les images du premier
journal télévisé français un jt sans
présentateur composée de seulement deux
reportages commentés en direct le
journaliste pierre sabbagh est l'un des
initiateurs du projet pour cette
première il fait dans le sensationnel et
survole paris en montgolfière une
expérience qu'il racontait 23 ans plus
tard nous étions quatre et ça s'est pas
très bien passé ce ballon invité une
fois deux fois
il ya une déchirure dans le ballon le
gaz s'est échappé sur étincelles s'est
enflammé michel d'activité n'a pas lâché
sa caméra on a vu arriver les gendarmes
pour nous emmener en prison parce que
qu'est-ce que c'est que c'est rigolo
télévision je ne suis en rien un journal
devient inexistant ça n'existait
absolument pas au début des années 50 la
télé est encore expérimentale et très
peu de français sont équipés d'un poste
le jt lui est diffusée tous les jours à
21h mais ne compte que très peu de
reportages pour enrichir le journal et
détaillé l'actualité les premiers
présentateurs apparaissent en 1954
mesdames et messieurs bonsoir le jt
prend alors la forme de celle qu'on
connaît encore aujourd'hui les
présentateurs sont en revanche plus
nombreux sur une même édition parfois 10
et leurs interventions beaucoup plus
long bonsoir mesdames on sort
mesdemoiselles bonsoir messieurs
il y a
[Musique]
vers l'an à la même période les premiers
duplex sont expérimentés le 24 juin 1955
en direct d'une mine de charbon de
merlebach en moselle
le journaliste robert west échanges avec
son collègue resté à paris
autre méthode pour les premiers duplex
avec l'étranger voici liaison paris
moscou en 1956 en direct les changes
film et se fait par téléphone
onze ans plus tard le 1er octobre 1967
la télé française passe à la couleur de
changement est progressif mais trois
jours plus tard les premiers reportages
it et en couleurs sont déjà visibles
100% masculin jusqu'au milieu des années
soixante dix le plateau du 20 heures ne
se féminise qu'à partir de 1976 27 ans
après le premier jt hélène vida devient
la première présentatrice du journal
télévisé
voilà maintenant la chasse à
l'automobiliste paul bert soixante dix
ans après sa création le jt s'est imposé
comme un emblème de la télévision en
2018 le 20 heures de france 2 et de tf1
réunissait en moyenne plus de 10
millions de téléspectateurs chaque soir
[Musique]